hey everyone this is Lucy and six months
ago I quit my job at AWS where I was
working as a Solutions architect many of
you might have seen this video where I
shared my thought process and reasoning
behind why I decided to leave but long
story short it was to give this whole
full-time YouTuber thing ago and wow A
lot has happened over the past six
months both with the tech industry as a
whole and my journey of being
self-employed I've gotten so many
questions asking me Lucy what is it
actually like being a full-time YouTuber
would you recommend it are you making
enough money and do you see yourself
doing this forever in this video I'm
going to be answering all of those
questions and provide an update on how
things are going so whether you're
someone looking to also quit your job
and pursue your passion or you're just
curious to hear what it's like working
on YouTube full-time then you've come to
the right place to make sure I cover
everything I'm going to break this video
up into five parts first I'll provide a
quick recap of the real reasons why I
decided to quit my job next I'll explain
the changes I had to make in my mindset
and daily routine since being
self-employed after that I'll talk about
some of my achievements and Pro progress
as well as what advice I have for those
who are considering a similar path and
finally I'll share what my plans are for
the next six months and Beyond I know we
have a lot to cover today so let's jump
straight into it I started making
YouTube videos around two and a half
years ago at the time I barely knew how
to use a proper camera and to be honest
I was quite terrified of uploading
videos but thankfully I convinced myself
to just give it a go because back in
University I've always enjoyed teaching
others and mentoring and YouTube just
seemed like the perfect place to do it
on after making about 10 videos it
became pretty clear to me that there was
a demand for the type of content I was
creating which at the time were videos
about my experience working at AWS I
started getting so many comments and
messages from viewers who really got
value out of the content I was sharing
and that gave me the motivation I needed
to continue however in my first year of
creating YouTube videos I made zero
dollars from it and so I had no idea I
could turn it into a full-time career
but as with the experience of many other
YouTubers I slowly learned how to
monetize my channel through ads
sponsorships and paid products and then
by the end of the second year my YouTube
income started to exceed the amount I
was earning at AWS now at that point I
was like okay Lucy if you don't take the
risk and do YouTube full-time you might
end up regretting it because you know
the channel is growing you get to do
what you love and you're making videos
that are really helping people my main
hesitation at the time though was that I
really enjoyed working at AWS I had an
amazing support network and there are
still times I look back and miss those
days but you know that's life and
sometimes we have to close off one
career path to pursue another since
leaving my job I've had to really shift
the way I think about work I have to
constantly remind myself that I'm no
longer an employee with a fixed salary
but someone with my own business and
brand that I'm responsible for it's kind
of scary sometimes because even though
being self-employed does give you the
freedom and flexibility it also means
that you have to be very
self-disciplined in order to stay on
track and so even though I don't have a
nine-to-five job now I still try to
stick to nine to five work hours and
take regular breaks because because if I
don't I end up just overworking or not
getting any work done I'm still trying
to figure out the perfect routine and
schedule but in a typical week I would
have blocks of time dedicated to script
writing video recording and editing
that's pretty much 90 of what I need to
do to keep the YouTube business up and
running but I also spend time these days
working on new business ideas and
building my technical skills another
mindset shift for me was making sure I
take the initiative to meet others who
are on the same journey of creating
content or building their own business
being self-employed can get pretty
lonely at times and so chatting with
others to understand the struggles and
challenges of running a business has
been very helpful in keeping me
motivated okay now I'd like to share
some of what I achieved over the past
six months and my progress on the things
I've been working on one of the most
visible achievements is channel growth
when I quit my job I remember having
around 40 000 subscribers and now at the
time we're recording this video we're
getting close to a hundred thousand
subscribers so thank you all so much
everyone for showing your support by
watching the videos and subscribing to
the channel aside from Channel growth
I've also been able to collaborate with
some amazing companies and those
Partnerships have allowed me to continue
providing free videos and resources for
our community companies like udemy I've
been recommending since the start of my
YouTube Journey so it's great that
they've reached out to support the
channel there's a whole bunch of other
stuff that happened over the past six
months for example I flew to the US for
the first time which was really fun I
moved to a new apartment where I set up
a dedicated recording space and I've
been invited to become a LinkedIn
learning instructor for an AWS course at
the time of recording this video I'm
also trying to create an email
newsletter so hopefully in the next few
weeks it will be ready to launch on the
money side of things my income from my
YouTube business is at around double of
what I was making at AWS and this is
mostly made up of YouTube ad Revenue
sponsorships Affiliates and one-on-one
career consultations to be honest it
still blows my mind that it's even
possible to make money through YouTube
but I'm very grateful to do what I love
without having to worry about paying the
bills before we continue I'd like to
take a moment to tell you about today's
video response on Lord VPN as a
full-time content creator I find myself
sometimes having to protect my internet
connection and privacy online nordvpn is
an easy to use VPN service that enables
you to access content from all over the
world whilst keeping your data and
applications safe whether you want to
hide your IP address or access content
only offered in certain countries
Northern VPN allows you to open up a map
click on a location and get connected in
seconds they now offer threat protection
which is a major upgrade that blocks
intrusive ads and web trackers so if you
download a file it would inspect for
malware it also automatically scans URLs
and blocks malicious ones if you're
looking for a VPN service to get head to
nordvpn.com forward slash lucitech to
get a two-year plan plus four additional
three months they have a 30 day money
back guarantee so you can try risk free
if this video has inspired you to start
your own YouTube channel or side hustle
my advice will be to just go for it when
I first started I had so many fears
around what other people would think or
what if all of this fails but for me the
potential regret of not giving it a go
was my much scarier I mean especially if
you're someone working in Tech with all
the tech layoffs happening at the moment
having an additional source of income
through a side hustle can really provide
more Financial Security and Independence
my recommendation is to find somebody
that lies in the intersection between
what you're interested in what you're
good at and what the world needs and
then once you start building and
creating try not to expect money to come
in straight away focus on providing
value to your target audience and the
rest will come after that for example if
you have an interest in personal finance
and you're the go-to person your friend
Circle for any money tips you could
start a finance Channel or if you enjoy
creating Tech tutorials and how-to
videos you could start a tech focused
YouTube channel like I did the key is to
find something that you enjoy doing and
that you're passionate about because I
think that's the only way to sustain
something in the long run I'm thinking
of creating a second Channel where I
share more of the behind the scenes of
What It's Like Doing YouTube full time
so if that's something that you might be
interested in please let me know in the
comments to wrap up here are some goals
I have for the next six months the first
one is to scale my business Beyond
YouTube I think being all in on a
platform can be quite risky so my goal
is to diversify my content across
platforms like LinkedIn Twitter and
Instagram another goal I have is to
continue learning and building my
technical skills because as we all know
things change so fast in the tech space
and finally because I know none of this
will be possible without all of your
support my third goal is to give back to
the community by doing more giveaways
sometimes people ask me if I see myself
doing this forever the answer is
probably not but what I know for certain
is that I'll actively be trying to work
for myself and only work for someone
else as a backup plan I actually got a
job offer from Google recently which I
ended up turning down but that's a story
for another day anyways this brings us
to the end of this video please give
this video a like if you enjoyed this
little life update and let me know your
thoughts in the comments below